tv
social media magazines it seems like
everywhere you look there's astrology
today a majority of young adults think
that astrology is science
and yeah they're not right but
historically they're not wrong
because for most of astrology's history
it was a serious science so how did
astrology turn into the billion dollar
biz we know today to find out
we gotta back it up
[Music]
from the aztecs to china's han dynasty
almost every culture has searched for
meaning among the stars
was born in second millennium bce when
babylonians first looked to the sky to
predict a variety of weather and
political matters
early astrology wasn't about personal
horoscopes it was more rudimentary
symbols like the shellfish were attached
to the stars to remind communities what
season they were in hey ishtar grab your
nets it's crab hunting season
gods were associated with specific
combos of planets and stars natural
phenomena were seen as messages
from the gods you know
an astrologist interpreted them marduk's
making thunder again is it just me or is
he angry about something that's not good
western horoscopic astrology first
emerged in the late 2nd century bce in
the mediterranean region this is when
the 12 signs in western astrology were
nailed down see there were actually 13
constellations but the babylonians
decided to ignore a fucus because they
already had a 12 month calendar and they
didn't want to make it more confusing
sorry serpent slayer of the stars
astrology
in the second century astrologer ptolemy
was obsessed with getting horoscopes to
be as accurate as possible he attempted
the first world map just so he could
chart the relationship between the
person's birthplace and the heavenly
bodies
and that's how we got geography
amazing
by the 13th century astrology had become
a part of everyday medical practice in
europe doctors in the 1500s were
required by law to calculate the
position of the moon before certain
medical operations such as surgery or
bloodletting
oh
oh yeah
astrology is all over classic literature
a pair of star-crossed lovers take their
life you know there's shakespeare
there's dante's inferno where
astrologers walk around hell in circles
with their heads twisted backwards
ouch
so maybe dante wasn't a fan but for a
long time astrology was accepted as
science look at tycho brahe galileo and
johann kepler they were scientists and
astrologers but their scientific
breakthroughs ended up destroying the
old order by decisively splitting
astronomy from astrology and by the 18th
century astrology was all but abandoned
astronomy is the science of the stars
astrology is a cult but you can't keep
the stars down
in the 20th century astrology saw two
popular revivals first alongside the
rise of spiritualism at the turn of the
century that's when carl jung started
developing psychological astrology which
led to the fun personality based
interpretations we obsess over today
oh notification
from co-star
have you ever thought about whether you
talk too
it's much of rude western astrology
again rose in popularity with the new
age philosophy in the 1960s or maybe it
was the age of aquarius you know the
rare conjunction of uranus representing
revolution and pluto representing
transformation
either way
the zodiac
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
and of course there is an astrological
revival taking place right now
after a dormant two decades the internet
has given astrology memes relevance
zodiac signs have become millennial
shorthand
i don't talk to gemini's honestly
they're faker than astrology so
yeah
astrology is no longer science but that
doesn't mean it's useless believing
things are fixed can be reassuring in
our chaotic lives reading a horoscope
describing a better future can help
people deal with stress and thinking
positively scientifically leads to more
positive outcomes so go ahead check your
star sign galileo did and isn't it just
so aquarius to obsess with the zodiac
and invent modern science
[Music]
so
[Music]